I am manchanda editor of Elle global
online and we have with us in our
studios someone who would be the best
guide for us to understand what's going
on in the Middle East specially in Libya
now since the Libyan crisis broke a new
acronym has appeared in media reports
it's something that sounds like the
robot of war
Star Wars is r2p r2p
responsibility to protect and this is a
principle that was actually converted
into a UN resolution in 2005 and the
person who was one of the chief
architects of this responsibility to
protect principle and subsequent will is
the former Australian Foreign Minister
Garrett events
welcome Garrett nice to be here now so
before I would like to actually give
your assessment of how this r2p has been
implemented so far but before that let's
step back and explain to us you know as
to what this responsibility means
especially in the context of sovereign
state which I came into existence as the
sovereignty concern of sovereignty in
1648 the Westphalia Peace and since then
sovereign states have been kind of
sacrosanct I cannot touch it and now
this responsibility to protect give the
responsibility to protect not only to
the sovereign states but to other
sovereign states and how did this
concept evolved what the issue is about
is how the world reacts to mass atrocity
crimes genocide major crimes against
humanity major war crimes
ethnic cleansing and it's important to
realize that for centuries the world was
fairly profoundly indifferent to such
atrocities catastrophes when they
occurred behind the walls of a sovereign
state as you just indicated the
Westphalian system of nation-states was
a form of sort of institutional
indifference to what happened behind
state walls you could almost say that
sovereignty was a license to kill that
didn't really change even with the
Holocaust the Second World War
yes we had the Genocide Convention along
with the Universal Declaration of Human
Rights the Nuremberg charter creating a
new category of crimes against humanity
even with that in the decades that
followed the Second World War and with
the creation of the United Nations the
dominant principle was still thou shalt
not interfere in the internal affairs of
sovereign states and that was
particularly reinforced by the number of
new countries joining the UN very
conscious of their fragility very proud
of their sovereign independence and with
a long history in many cases of
interference and in domination plenty of
domination and civilizing missions
missing on sibylla's of trees from the
the great powers and they didn't want
any recognition or acknowledgement even
though of course they were unhappy about
the news of these atrocities occurring
from time to time they were very was a
consensus free zone when it came to
determining in international reaction so
the world stood by and watched the
Cambodian genocide the world stood by
and watched idiom in perform multiple
atrocities in Uganda the world stood by
while with Pakistan West Pakistan army
moved into what is now Spengler desh and
when countries did intervene tenzin a
year in the case of Uganda Vietnam in
the case of Cambodia they were
criticized for interfering in internal
affairs it did look as though we might
be moving towards a more civilized
approach to these things in the 90s
after the end of the Cold War but
immediately there were new controversies
no what why why the end of the Cold War
is a marker for this changing attitude
towards because that was a period in
which it seemed possible for the
Security Council to work as a collective
whole rather than being fanatical about
particular Cold War verities and
positions and
it was perfectly understandable during
the Cold War II is such were the
tensions on the Security Council there
was just impossible to reach agreement
about how to respond to these situations
there's no consensus at all but with the
end of the Cold War there's a degree of
optimism that maybe this would change
but it didn't and so we had year after
year after year we can all remember in
the 1990s the problems in Somalia
ineffectual international intervention
then the catastrophic situation in
Rwanda in 1994 while the world stood by
and watched while 800,000 people were
butchered in the space of a few weeks
and then almost unbelievably just a year
later and the Balkans wars in sibron
itza UN peacekeepers kind of standing by
while seven or eight thousand young men
and boys were taken out of the town of
Severn itza and butchered then we had
the Kosovo situation which was a an
international response to another mass
atrocity ethnic cleansing situation that
was looming but there was no agreement
about how to respond because they did
because the Security Council couldn't
reach agreement the Russians to veto but
why the objection of some countries to
intervene because they had some stake in
that country or is it because they saw
in president that could be applied to
their yeah it was just the principle
because the problem was the way the
issue was couched in the 1990s there was
the this language of humanitarian
intervention or the right to intervene
Bernard Kirchner later French Foreign
Minister to odd entrants the right to
intervene and state said look we're not
going to concede any such principle that
there is a right to intervene in our
affairs we're conscious of a sovereign
independence etc etc and even though yes
these are occasions for concern there's
a greater principle here which we don't
want to acknowledge so you had in the
North this rallying cry of the right to
intervene and in the South this great
defensive necesidad international
sovereignty so this is the context in
which the responsibility to protect is
born and you have to understand the
background to understand how significant
a change this is Kofi Annan addressed
the General Assembly of the
in 2000 and said if responsibility to
protect sorry if the right to intervene
if humanitarian intervention is such a
shocking assault on the principles of
state sovereignty how then should we
react to these conscience shocking
crimes against humanity that we've all
witnessed that challenge was one that
the Canadian government actually picked
up by establishing the International
Commission on intervention and state
sovereignty which I co-chaired yes that
caution which Lee Hamilton for example
was a member from the US called
International Commission on intervention
and sovereignty and that gave birth to
this concept of the responsibility to
protect that was the title of our report
and that's what we put into the public
domain in 2001 and the core concepts if
I can summarize it very very briefly the
first big thing was the linguistic
conceptual shift instead of talking
about a right of anyone to throw their
weight around or do anything we talked
about the responsibility of everyone
starting with the sovereign state itself
instead of talking about intervention as
the key concept we talked about
protection as the key concept because
the way the right to intervene had been
expressed it was sinned in the Marines
in I think it was all about military
intervention and no wonder that made
people very near algae so it was the
first thing second thing was to make
clear that there was a multi-layered
responsibility the responsibility began
with the sovereign state itself to
protect its own people to do no harm
responsibility the second dimension of
it was the responsibility of other
states to assist that state if it was in
a mood to be assisted with whatever
resources have needed to deal with the
situation that was getting out of hand
internally and the third layer
responsibility was that of the wider
international community to engage in
whatever way was necessary to solve the
problem if a state was manifestly
failing to exercise that responsibility
no and the language there was pretty
interesting because the world military
was not used but the language was we are
prepared to take collective action in a
timely and decisive manner through the
Security Council in accordance with the
Charter include
in chapter 2 chapter 7 chapter 7 sorry
on a case-by-case basis and in
cooperation with regional organizations
as appropriate should peaceful means be
inadequate so this piece this means
being inadequate
was the indirect craft saying there
should be non peaceful collective action
yeah this is this you're jumping ahead
to 2005 when we had the sequence of race
the Commission produced its report came
up with this concept and then after
another chain of things which we needn't
go into in 2005 rather spectacularly and
unexpectedly the World Summit 150 plus
leaders heads of state and government
actually signed up to this principle in
the way in which I've expressed it the
third element of the principle which is
reflected in the language that you
identified is that military action under
Chapter 7 of the UN Charter is retained
as an option but only in extreme
circumstances so the the further
important contribution of this content
was not only turning the language upside
down and reconceptualizing it in a more
acceptable language but it also made
clear that the military dimension of it
while still needed to be there was a
last resort and there was only should
peaceful means had not be possible to
resolve the situation and only if the UN
Security Council should endorse it so
that's where we got to in 2005 and I
think it's important to have pre P
appreciate just what a big conceptual
breakthrough that was the big question
mark however was was this just going to
be a rhetorical breakthrough or was it
going to stick in terms of actually
that's why I think maybe we can just
jump ahead to this year when I think in
February the organization that you
headed International Crisis Group issued
a report in mid-february calling for the
international intervention on principle
or the sponsor will protect Libya but it
took more than a month for the
organization you went to actually agree
to pass the resolution yeah I don't
think we all should be unhappy about
that this is these are always going to
be complex and
difficult issues is always going to be a
lot of argument the immediate need was
to get to the stage where there was a
reflex response internationally not that
this was nobody's business which was the
reaction of the past but that it's
everyone's business how that response
should play itself out there are bound
to be disagreements arguments caution a
lot of the international community while
now prepared to accept this principle
and in successive UN debates they have
accepted it it's only just a handful of
countries now deny it all together there
will always be argument about how to do
it now what happened in the Libya case
is really I think a textbook example of
how the principle should be applied it
started out there were two resolutions
the first one in February was a strong
call for the cessation by the Libyan
government all offensive action against
its own civilians a call for a
condemnation of that and the application
of what by UN standards are very strong
measures targeted sanctions an arms
embargo and a reference of the whole
issue to the International Criminal
Court raising the specter of
international criminal law action
against Gaddafi and is and he's senior
intrument that was a major breakthrough
itself because you had the
responsibility to protect principle
expressly invoked and you had a set of
really very strong measures agreed on to
apply that and that was a unanimous
decision however of course it didn't
work it didn't stop the violence
Gaddafi ignored the ceasefire calls
ignored any invitation to negotiate a
political solution and kept up the
barrage moreover threatened if he ever
got hold of the the rebels the
dissidents to basically wipe them out
exterminate them and then you had this
beginnings of a movement of military
action tanks armored personnel moving
towards Benghazi the east of the country
and so everybody was acutely conscious
that here in the making maybe just two
or three days away was a catastrophic
mass-murder situation looming classic
case for the application of the most
extreme end of the responsibility to
protect spectrum it's not surprising
that it took some time for consensus to
be reached about how to deal with this
and the Americans I think are not to be
blamed President Obama is not to be
blamed for not wanting to move on this
until he was confident that the voice of
the region was supporting such a strong
action so President Obama waited until
he had expressed support from the Arab
League's and when it did come the US
moved very quickly and they it was it
was a difficult debate stool because you
had Russia and China and India and
Brazil and Germany all abstaining so but
an abstention was as good as an
affirmative vote particularly from US
and China because they didn't have
basically from Russia and China because
they didn't they didn't veto and so we
had this further resolution passed which
authorizes all necessary measures ie
military measures short our boots on the
ground short of an occupying force but
not only the imposition of a no-fly zone
but also other necessary action which
has taken of course the form of airborne
assaults on tank movements and so on so
here we had for the first time not only
a invocation of the principle as in the
first resolution but it's actual
complete application and the forms of
military action so let's I think to be
applauded because whatever else is going
on and whatever other difficult policy
questions remain and there are quite a
few will no doubt talk about them let's
remember let's progress the fact that
that we stopped a massacre the world
agreed to stop what would certainly have
been very fast rally yeah mass atrocity
crime No
where they in the intervention has gone
on it seemed to respect not respect
aerial sovereignty that you can go over
Libyan airspace and bomb and and shoot
at tanks but you are not going to
violate that territorial sovereignty on
the on the ground now this this
restriction on the intervention
basically means what you said that no
boots on the ground means that the
battery has not changed his tactics he
only is not using tanks he losing pickup
trucks and SUVs to carry his troops and
and NATO is unable to identify them and
shoot them so there is a concrete
example of the limits of the response to
protect principle applied in Libya well
I think what the international community
was doing was really trying to
neutralize the prospects of a major
civilian massacre of the kind that would
have occurred had arrived in Benghazi
there were remaining civilian protection
questions I mean what Gaddafi was doing
to his own people in the areas under his
control and Tripoli for example which
were not going to be able to be
addressed as you say except by a
full-scale invasion but what was clear
is the mood of the region was not in
favor of that and when you are applying
these responsibilities to protect
principles particularly at the extreme
end of military action you do have to
apply not only a legal benchmark of
Security Council approval you also have
to apply a Prudential benchmark and one
of the issues that you have to bring
into the equation is whether more harm
than good would be caused by taking the
action in question and I think right
from the beginning there's been a very
real acknowledged risk that if you have
Western forces physically on the ground
engaged in not just stopping an easily
definable civilian protection assault
but really engaged in a full-scale
ground war
against a governing regime was a very
real risk that that would be able to be
portrayed in the Arab Islamic world as
here come the Crusaders again here the
year of the Western armies here are the
infidels and and the Arabs themselves
didn't want that and the rebels on the
ground were initially anyway content
with the proposition of taking out
Gaddafi's air superiority and they were
particularly happy about taking out you
know sort of ground yeah assault what
we've now got frankly is is now I'm much
more like a familiar of civil war
situation and what the international
community has got to decide is whether
is going to take full-scale sides in a
civil war situation treated not just as
a civilian protection responsibility to
protect case but an international peace
and security issue of a familiar kind
and it's got to make some tough
decisions about this and it may be that
we're in for a stalemate of a
protractors daily but remember remember
that we still do have the target of
sanctions remember we still have the
threat of international criminal court
prosecution we still have a massive
diplomatic effort going on we still have
the pressure being applied by attacks on
concentrations of Gaddafi's forces now
by any familiar historical standard
that's not a bad set of measures for the
internationals to agree on and hopefully
over time this will encourage collapse
from within of the regime defections and
so on and I and a political solution to
this you can't win all these things by
military military means yes but I think
the situation the way it is now today we
are talking here on a Friday of 8th of
April the Gaddafi forces have now
basically thrown out the rebels from
Brega and actually heading towards
Benghazi so we might be seeing another
sort of replay of what happened when the
first intimation we may see multiple
replies of this and that's maybe just
the way it will have to go but I think
if you start playing games with the
language of that resolu
and use it as an all-purpose authority
to mount full-scale war to achieve
regime change you're going beyond the
consensus that is there in that
resolution now in terms of getting rid
of Gaddafi we might all agree that it
would be a wholly desirable objective we
might also agree that ultimately that
may will be the only way to completely
be confident that there won't be any
more civilians at risk anywhere but if
we want to preserve the integrity of
responsibility to protect principle if
we want to preserve the capacity for
building consensus around this in the
future so that there's another Rwanda
situation if there's another Severn
Easter situation if there's another
Kosovo situation or if there is another
Benghazi situation in another country in
the future we want to preserve the the
willingness to unite around a resolution
if we play as an international community
too fast and loose with that language
without going back and getting refined
language agreed we are going to play
into the hands of all those who say look
right from the beginning this
responsibility to protect thing as just
being a cover for the old familiar
Western Imperial attitudes they're just
looking for an excuse to come in and
throw their weight around yes not what
responsibilities protectors either but
it's it's crucial that we we keep it as
tight and narrowly defined as we
possibly can so if that is the next step
in terms of refining this responsible
protect what would be your suggestion in
the light of the experience that we have
had so far in the Libyan case Libyan was
more generally again I think it's a
steady process of consolidation
I mean we've come a long way 2005 was
the rhetoric or the formal achievement
the period since then has been a slow
halting process of increasing the
consensus about what is and what is not
a responsibility to protect case I think
the high-water mark before Libya in the
use of the concept was Kenya in 2008
when you may remember there was a
catastrophic violence erupted after a
disputed election we had church burnings
P
being killed tens of thousands of people
expel from their homes and it looked
like a replay of Rwanda but everybody
started talking about the responsibility
to protect and a diplomatic mission was
mobilized led by Kofi Annan which
diffused the situation short of any
military means it was a classic example
of the lesser persuasive measures being
since then we have had Sri Lanka
overhead Sri Lanka and then we've had
Darfur and we've had the Congo where
there's been imperfect and incomplete
and we've also had the misuse of the
concept by Russia in 2008 when it
invaded South Ossetia and in mess in
Macedonia both Macedonia in Georgia
can't be started and livid I'll just
repeat the that sentence again and then
of course we've not only had the sri
lankan case that you mentioned the
Darfur inadequacy of the rebels the
Congo case but we've also had a misuse
of the responsibility to protect
principle by Russia when it invaded
Georgia in 2008 claiming that it was
protecting civilians when clearly it was
doing nothing of the kind
this has been a halting process the
Libya the Libya case I think represents
a high-water mark of the application of
this it's important that that not be the
high-water mark from which the tide now
recedes
but to for the future we need to do a
number of things we need to continue to
refine the principle conceptually so
everybody understands what it's about
and recognizes that it's different from
conflict situations generally in human
rights violation situations generally is
only for the most extreme mass atrocity
crimes we need institutional
preparedness we need to create early
warning and response centers in every
major government and instant in
intergovernmental institution we need to
create civilian preparedness negotiators
mediators police able to go into these
situations we need to rethink the kind
of military configurations and doctrine
and training that are needed for these
fire brigade jobs which are short of
traditional war fighting so all and
above all we need further effort to
generate political consensus case by
case as it arise
so there's a big task ahead but I'm very
confident that step by step by step as
we go through this learning process we
will get more and more international
consensus the important thing is not to
blow it by misusing the concept yes and
and one thing that you did not mention
which i think is worth mentioning is the
role of the media in bringing people to
the attention of the atrocities about to
take place or first taking place which
was absent in a lot of past atrocities
here people are sending their cell phone
photographs yeah yeah to youtube or
particularly the news in new media this
is the new social media unquestionably
playing a major role in ensuring that
nobody has any excuses anymore for not
knowing not about these things it's not
necessarily going to make it easier to
generate the necessary consensus about
how to respond that's always going to be
tricky always going to be difficult
always going to be argument always going
to be step-by-step always going to be a
question mark about whether the ultimate
response really is effective enough that
when we compare where we got to in Kenya
in 2008 with the absolute indifference
of the international community to the
unfolding tragedy in Rwanda just 14
years earlier when we compared the
response to Libya with the response to
sober needs and Kosovo in terms of the
unanimity will the agreement that was
achieved in the Security Council we've
come a very long way and I think if you
stand back from this it's very hard to
think in the history of ideas and the
history of international relations any
fundamental new principle that is caught
on as quickly as this one has yes it's
imperfect yes there's still journalists
who misunderstand it and misuse it still
there are academics who are living back
in the days of humanitarian intervention
and talking to each other about you know
complex issues of interpretation which
have got nothing to do with the real
world that's going on of international
political policy debate right now things
have shift there is
think close now to an international
reflex response that when these
situations arise which everyone can
recognize as as catastrophic we have to
do something that is very very important
to tell our viewers that Libya does mark
a high watershed and the responsibility
of the world today is to move on from
there and not proceed from there and in
order to give the better background to
what happened and how it happened
nothing is better than this book that
Gareth Evans wrote and published in 2008
it is extremely relevant today to
understand what is going in going on in
Libya Gareth Evans thank you so much for
spending the time with us thank you very
much now I appreciate the opportunity to
talk to you as always thank you